Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, thanks to everyone
who submitted questions for this week’s
Doctor Who Q&A.
Lot’s of good Missy and Danny theories,
and I also wanted to add that yes.
That is Ellis George in the teaser for the
next episode, Kill the Moon, but she’s not
listed on the cast of any of the rest of the
episodes this year.
I’ll be sure to include new information
if anything about that changes.
There are some interesting castings for episodes
8 through the finale but I’ll talk more
about them when those episodes get here.
Heads up too, The Doctor Who Legacy video
game people reached out to me about doing
a special giveaway for episode 7 this saturday,
so be sure to subscribe to get that video.
Question time, careful for spoilers from this
week’s episode in case you haven’t seen
it yet.
I’ll wait just a sec... okay, here we go.
1 - Tasman Devil asks Will there be more Courtney
Woods in the future, do you think she’ll
die and go to Missy?
I already answered the first part of that,
I do think your second part is interesting.
Moffat is the writer, and he is probably going
for maximum cry levels.
Killing a child feels a little too cruel though,
even for him.
I know there have been times during Classic
Who when children died, but just going on
Moffat’s own personal history, I think it’s
more likely he’d kill an adult beloved character.
Something about killing innocent children
just makes it feel like something the BBC
wouldn’t want him to do.
2 - Dragon Fly Noir asks do you agree with
the criticism that Doctor Who this season
has been too similar to Sherlock?
I haven’t seen a lot of that sentiment on
the videos I’ve been doing for Doctor Who
this year so I’ll assume you're talking
about professional critics.
I noticed a lot of Sherlocky-ness in the premiere,
but I think that’s because Vastra’s character
has always been linked to Sherlock Holmes.
I think any connection to Benedict Cumberbatch’s
Sherlock Series is coincidence.
Yes there are Sherlock overtones, but I think
when we’ve seen them, they’ve been endemic
to the characters.
Now if they played the Sherlock BBC theme
song in the background.
That would probably be too much.
3 - Andrew asks, what was the bit with the
Planet in the beginning all about?
The montage was just way to show Clara was
constantly running from adventure to adventure
with the Doctor in between school.
I’m not sure what the planet they were on
was, but if anyone thinks they know just write
it in the comments.
They also visited fish people and a bunch
of other places.
It gives you a sense of the sheer quantity
of stories happening that we never get to
witness.
Like we only see the doctor for about 50 minutes
a week which comprises a single adventure.
But outside of that he could being going on
hundreds of other adventures.
That’s really where the expanded material
picks things up.
4 - Alex Wilcox asks, do you think Danny and
Clara will get married and they’ll use that
as the excuse if Jenna Coleman to leaves the
show?
I think they’re definitely pushing them
in that direction.
Most of the romantic companions in recent
years have gotten pseudo happy endings, like
Amy got Rory, Rose got a version of The Doctor.
It might be Moffat setting up a huge twist.
I think he’ll make everyone really happy
with the idea that Clara will get married
and have a wonderful life and then yank the
rug out from under us.
It just feels like the very TV-thing to do.
Make you love a character, then kill them
off.
5 - Chris Paul asks, what do you think the
best episode so far is?
Right now it’s still Listen, but based on
what the Doctor Who people are saying about
Kill the Moon, that might end up being the
fan favorite.
6 - Drew asks what do you think the policeman
saw through the window at the end?
When you rewatch the scene you can see Chris
Addison from In the Thick of it, smiling.
Like he’s very happy revealing the policeman’s
new environment.
But the policeman is in complete shock.
Not the kind of shock you see on someone’s
face christmas morning opening gifts.
The kind of shock you see on someone’s face
when they’re told they have cancer.
It looks a little bit like Horror.
Something about what he saw fundamentally
changed his core belief system.
Just to differentiate.
Terror is the fear you feel when a giant moon
spider is chasing you.
It doesn’t make you question your identity.
Horror is a profound shock to your belief
system.
Like Oswin Oswald realizing she had been turned
into a Dalek.
That’s genuine Horror.
And it looks like that’s what’s going
on here.
7 - a person asks, what’s with all the shared
Moffat Writing Credits on episodes this year?
I’ve heard a lot of rumors flying around
about drama in the production offices, but
mostly I think it’s because of the story
structure this year.
They’re making episode less serialized,
but they still have to service the overarching
plots like Missy and Danny Pink with Clara.
Part of Moffat’s role as showrunner is to
make sure they don’t lose sight of those
things.
So he probably jumped on a lot of the scripts
to make sure they tied in with things we’ll
see happening in the finale.
I’m sure he does a lot of other edits to
the stories, but in general.
Adding a writing credit for himself to a script
means he wrote a significant portion of it
himself.
Those parts being the big stuff going on in
the background.
8 - Why Not asks, I miss the big Epic Moments
that Matt Smith got, do you think we’ll
get some of those this year?
Part of the reason Matt Smith got those crazy
big moments was because his run was more serialized,
so they had more time to build up to big payoffs.
Yes I do think we’ll get some major Capaldi
moments, but I think we won’t start seeing
those developing till much later in the series.
Episode 7 is supposed to be pretty epic though.
Bloggers are saying it will change the course
of the series.
9 - Colin Daley asks do you think Danny Pink
being on the TARDIS this year will cause The
Doctor to go darker and become the valeyard?
I actually think The Doctor will warm up
to Danny, maybe not as much as the 11th Doctor
warmed up to Rory, but as warm as a grumpy
old Scottish Doctor can get.
Trust is a big theme this year, so it makes
sense that The Doctor and Danny would start
to trust each other right as that trust gets
broken.
As for the valeyard no, I don’t think he’s
going to turn into the Valeyard.
10 - Mr Nobody asks what does Ozzie loves
the Squaddie mean?
It’s shorthand for Clara loves Danny.
Ozzie as in Oswald and Squaddie is a reference
to Military Squadron.
Clara and Danny made a remark early in the
episode where Clara asks Danny if the girls
including Courtney there, know about the two
of them dating.
Danny said possibly, they’re children, they’ve
got minds of their own.
I think it just says something about the intelligence
of Children.
Like children are much more perceptive than
adults.
Maybe we’ll see more of that play out with
the Courtney character in episode 7.
Thanks so much everyone for submitting questions
though.
And congratulations to Super Duck, you’re
this week’s giveaway winner.
You win an amazon giftcard.
I’ll message you on your channel for details.
Also, good news.
The people at the Doctor Who Legacy game reached
out to me about doing a special giveaway.
So I’ll have a gift code all of you will
be able to use.
I’ll be releasing the code when I post my
Episode 7 video.
Everyone will be able to use it.
It won’t be a contest or anything.
I’ve got a bunch of other videos I’m trying
to get out in the next couple of days, you
can follow me on twitter and facebook if you
want to learn more about those.
Right now click here for my bonus doctor who
challenge video and click here for my episode
6 review.
Thanks for watching, let’s all high five
and meet up tomorrow for gotham.